[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans parlement hebdo
26 minutes pour revoir les temps forts
de l'actualité à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat est notre invité aujourd'hui
avec tam traduit est un sénateur nous
accueillons hervé marseille bonjour l'on
est cet homme qui va faire votre
portrait avec marseille bonjour alors
vous êtes sénateur des hauts-de-seine
président du groupe union centriste est
actuellement président délégué de l'uwe
des arts le groupe union centriste c'est
l'une des jambes de la majorité
sénatoriale
vous avez souvent pesté comme beaucoup
dans la majorité contre l'attitude du
gouvernement à l'égard du sénat lors du
précédent quinquennat le sénat a mis de
côté parfois à bout des seins de
certains ministres alors depuis le
gouvernement a largement changé de ton
mais est-ce que vous pensez que les
actes vont suivre est ce que vous
observez outre les déclarations d'amour
un vrai changement de méthode côté il
n'ya pas encore totalement une méthode
il faut reconnaître qu'il ya un
tâtonnement mais c'est normal puisque on
change de culture et cette culture elle
ne s'acquiert pas aussi rapidement qu'on
le voudrait obama encore nice oui vous
l'avez dit cinq ans le sénat ait été
évité j'ai eu à chaque fois que les
ministres passés rue de vaugirard il
accélérait devient incontournable bien
sûr les électeurs ont fait
un choix nous avons une assemblée
nationale où il n'y a pas de majorité il
faut trouver des majorités donc il faut
ouvrir le dialogue et rechercher des
compromis c'est bien parti le mentalisme
forcé par la majorité relative à
l'assemblée nationale on y arrive mais
contraint et forcé bah écoutez nécessité
fait loi mais je pense que c'est une
bonne chose d'ailleurs à des sondages
montrent que les français apprécient ce
renouveau du dialogue au parlement à
condition de trouver des solutions parce
qu'ils n'ont plus ils ne veulent pas le
bazar donc on ne voit pas le blocage en
évoquer un éventuel blocage sur des
textes pour l'instant c'est pas ce qui
se passe mais il faut que chacun accepte
aussi de faire des compromis ce qui
n'est pas facile vous croyez que c'est
possible devient sur l'a35 à ces textes
qui sont ou étaient alors bon c'est un
peu sur les chapeaux de roue il faut
reconnaître que l'image que donne un
certain nombre de groupes à l'assemblée
nationale est pas totalement
satisfaisante vous pensez à qui alla du
ps en particulier ou à l'évidence il ya
des comportements qui sont comment on
dit inapproprié fut-ce l'animent que le
rassemblement national au niveau des
extraits rassemblement national voulons
observer j'observe j'observe que ce
qu'ils appellent la stratégie de la
cravate c'est à dire
contrairement justement aux élus de la
nuque mais ce qui arrive un peu
débraillé en vociférant
cette image de respectabilité
usagers l'accès c'est inquiétant cette
respectabilité du rassemblement national
où vous dites bon ben il joue le jeu et
donc ils sont plus fréquentable
aujourd'hui je trouve que cette
dédiabolisation
organisée eux qui n'est pas nouvelle
cette respectabilité recherché
est préoccupante en tous les cas je
pense pour l'avenir puisque on a vu
marine le pen était au second tour des
élections présidentielles avec 42% des
voix avec les live tient ses troupes son
groupe à l'assemblée un sur la brise
donc je la vois progresser je la vois
progresser en images est certainement
sur le terrain il y en a même certains
au niveau de la majorité présidentielle
qui disent on a l'impression et le 10
ans offre que c'est le nouveau rpr le
rassemblement national
je sais pas si on peut aller jusque là
mais enfin c'est à nous de nous
ressaisir et 7 aux formations politiques
la droite républicaine et au centre de
faire en sorte que ça n'aille pas plus
loin on va voir comment ça peut
s'appliquer sur les textes avec
l'assemblée nationale qui adopte le
projet de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat les
députés ont donné leur feu vert aux
primes et autres revalorisation de
prestations sociales des débats
tumultueux et tendu entre la majorité et
les oppositions surtout la nuque
députés et sénateurs sont tombés
d'accord sur le projet de loi sanitaire
un texte finalement très proche de la
version écrite par le sénat avec le
contrôle des voyageurs en cas de
variantes dangereux et la possible
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
enfin les incendies au coeur de la
séance de questions au gouvernement au
sénat les sénateurs réclament plus de
canadairs et déplore une flotte
vieillissante
il était 5 heures 50 dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale après plus de
trente huit heures de débat tumultueux
les députés ont fini par voter au
forceps le projet loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat le texte instaure une série de
mesures d'urgence pour faire face à
l'inflation les oppositions ont fait
entendre leur voix défendant pied à pied
certains amendements compte rendu d'une
semaine très agitée avec stéphanie de
pierre
c'est le premier grand test pour le camp
présidentiel
sans majorité absolue à l'assemblée le
gouvernement c'est dès l'ouverture des
débats qu'il va devoir chercher des voix
dans l'opposition pour faire adopter son
paquet pouvoir d'achat et ils regardent
du côté des républicains la majorité
sera ouverte
à toutes les propositions constructives
simplement nous n'entrerons pas dans une
logique de surenchère nous voulons le
compromis mais le compromis ne s'achète
pas à coup de milliards le compromis ne
finance pas sur le dos du contribuable
mais de véritable compromis il n'y en
aura qu'un seul sur la d conjugale
isation de l'allocation adultes
handicapés les personnes handicapées ne
perdront plus une partie de l'aide
lorsqu'elle se mettront en couple une
réforme réclamée de longue date par les
oppositions et voté à la quasi unanimité
je crois que s'il ya un sujet qui mérite
ce soir alors que nous sommes combattus
tout au long de ce texte de voter
ensemble c'est bien celui qui va
permettre la déconvenue gars lisation de
la hache pour le reste seuls quelques
amendements de l'opposition sont adoptés
souvent qu'on la nuque ps les verts et
le rn votre ensemble la majorité a fait
passer l'augmentation de la prime macron
la revalorisation des pensions et des
prestations sociales l'assouplissement
de l'intéressement et la limitation des
hausses de loyer mais les longs débats
ont tourné au face à face entre
renaissance et la nuque ps ce que vous
êtes en train de faire la part votre
lointaine de leur donner l'occasion de
ne pas augmenter les salaires avec des
primes avec lise de l'intéressement vous
n'êtes là que pour empêcher les gens de
vivre mieux et vous devriez avoir honte
contenu de votre niveau de vie
nous acceptons depuis le début depuis le
début de l'examen des heures et des
heures
d'invectivés d'interpellations d'
insulte qui ne cessent de fuser de cette
partie de l'hémicycle mais à un moment
ça suffit
finalement le texte est adopté un peu
avant 6 heures du matin vendredi les
nerfs et le rn ont voté pour la nuque ps
a voté contre à l'exception d'une
quinzaine de socialistes et de quatre
communistes qui se sont absentés 1
hervé marseille vient finalement ce
projet de loi dont on disait que les
débats allaient tarder s'éterniser
peut-être se poursuivent encore il a
finalement été adopté un peu au forceps
et au bout de la nuit mais ça veut dire
quand même que qu'il est possible de
trouver des compromis tout à fait et je
crois que c'est indispensable parce que
si la parlement
reprend des responsabilités retrouve
force et vigueur il faut être à la
hauteur des attentes des français il
faut se montrer responsables et donc il
faut trouver des accommodements et donc
des rechercher des solutions dont tout
le monde pour vous s'est montré
responsable
est ce que le texte a été adopté grâce à
l'attitude ou au rôle de certains
groupes en particulier
ou alors est-ce que c'est l'oeuvre de
tous écoutez l'essentiel c'est qu'ils
aient un texte et qui est un vote après
peut mieux faire vous pouvez voter un
tel texte en l'état on l'a vu finalement
il ya plus des sujets consensuels qui
ont été adoptées que de réel compromis
qui ont été bâties peut-être à paroles
l'allocation adulte handicapé t nous au
groupe union centriste par exemple on va
défendre une taxation des supers profits
ça a été évoqué à l'assemblée nationale
mais on peut pas d'un côté
faire en sorte que la collectivité c'est
à dire nous tous peillon d'échec pour
que les gens se chauffe ou mange et puis
de l'autre côté avoir des sociétés qui
du fait
des surcoûts pétrolier gagne des
milliards et des milliards
notamment cinéma etc ça se fait partout
en europe partout en europe
je pense que s'il ya une taxation à
hauteur de 20% par rapport à une
augmentation à lisser sur les dernières
années de ces entreprises là c'est pas
mortelle pour ces entreprises et c'est
bon pour le budget de la france
temporaire vous en attendez bien sûr ce
serait temporaire je pense qu'on peut
faire ça pendant déjà pendant un an et
puis sur une seconde année si les
profits continuent d'augmenter ce serait
la moindre des choses c'est tu désires
bien sûr on peut pas demander la
solidarité nationale et de l'autre côté
avoir des actionnaires qui prennent de
l'argent on veut vous entendre avec la
nuque sur ce point là vous avez vu
beaucoup de d'amendements sur une
demande la taxation des supers mais il
ya des idées partout tous les jours on
va me dire oui mais ça la nuque la
demande et ça le fn l'a demandé ça intel
a donc les riches sont bonnes une perte
de l'attractivité de l'économie
française parce que ça c'est c'est
l'argument c'est un truc gouvernement
par l'instant qui suit ne rien faire on
trouve à tous les arguments en revanche
si les espagnols les allemands les
anglais les italiens
les autrichiens le fonds voit pourquoi
la france pourrait pas le faire alors à
l'unanimité moins une voix les députés
ont voté l'individualisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui va des
couples et le versement de cette
allocation des revenus du bénéficiaire
il ya eu beaucoup de textes ici ça n'a
jamais abouti la majorité n'en voulait
pas comment vous expliquez que
maintenant ce soit enfant a voté
unanimement ça c'est le pouvoir du
parlement s'est jamais trop tard pour
bien faire ça a été une idée qui n'a pas
été retenu dans le monde cette saison
ils changent pas d'avis nous disait cet
effet le président de la république
pendant sa campagne l'a proposé mais
cette fois c'est alléluia maintenant
c'est voter mais il ya encore quarante
quatre mille
personnes concernées pour qui ça va être
une moins value oui donc il va falloir
y a pas que des gagnants 1 d'ailleurs il
ya aussi la rapporteure heller ici au
sénat frédérique puissat qui a dit c'est
une mesure électoraliste qui n'a rien à
faire dans ce texte est-ce que donc il
va falloir travailler ici le texte je
pense au sénat ce sera votre rôle ça ça
sera nous regrettons très bientôt dès la
semaine prochaine oui parce que le sénat
n'est pas la chambre d'appel de
l'assemblée nationale nous nous sommes
un vecteur d'amélioration
c'est pas parce que quelque chose se
fait pas ou mal à l'assemblée nationale
faut faire appel au sénat en disant on
va remettre les choses d'aplomb non nous
nous sommes un vecteur d'amélioration
dernière petite question sur quelque
chose d'important dans ce texte il a été
voté une prime en tout cas on va les
entreprises pourront donner plus de
primes en échange d'exonérations vous
êtes plutôt prime ou plutôt hausses de
salaires
un bouquet la situation quand il ya une
telle inflation d'avoir des primes j'y
reste à la discrétion des entreprises
les primes elles sont ciblées et sont
temporaires et il faut les prendre après
l'augmentation des salaires c'est
contribuer à l'inflation il faut
travailler dans le partenariat avec les
syndicats et les entreprises on peut pas
le décider autoritairement vous préparez
aussi des mesures d'ailleurs pour aider
les collectivités à faire face aux
effets de l'augmentation du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires territoriaux
quelle mesure vous préparer oui parce
que c'est une technique habituelle de
l'état c'est-à-dire vous l'état décide
et vous vous payez donc c'est trop
facile et nous nous allons proposer un
bouclier
tarifaire pour les collectivités
territoriales
je veux pas rentrer dans les mécaniques
mais là où on va sur une période donnée
constaté une augmentation trop forte des
dépenses dans les collectivités
d'énergie et bien il faudra que l'état
compense à hauteur de 50% cette
augmentation c'est un bouclier
nécessaire parce que c'est que l'énergie
c'est pas forcément sur l'augmentation
du point d'indicé pas forcément mais sur
déjà sur l'énergie pourquoi parce que
les collectivités sont armand parts
sociales les cantines le sport la
culture c'est un rempart sociale si les
collectivités sont affaiblis et bien les
familles seront moins aidés parce que
les collectivités n'auront plus la
possibilité dans ce paquet pouvoir
d'achat en discussion et à la question
du prix du carburant treize élus penser
qu'il y aura un geste qu'il faut
attendre un geste qu'il faut que soit
inscrit dans ce texte qui peut y avoir
un compromis pour baisser le prix du
litre on va en discuter nous nous par
exemple dans mon groupe
on souhaite proposer que les employeurs
puissent avoir des cotisations sociales
défalquer hauteur de ce qu'ils donnent à
leurs salariés parce que vous avez
beaucoup de gens notamment en province
qui utilisent leur voiture pour aller
travailler parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autres moyens ce qui n'est pas le cas
chez nous en région parisienne métro il
les trains étaient râler les bus quand
vous êtes dans ce qu'on appelle les
territoires il faut utiliser sa voiture
donc faudrait pouvoir aider les
employeurs et faire en sorte qu'ils
aient moins de cotisations sociales en
contrepartie des aides aux salariés elle
est on va continuer avec le projet de
loi sanitaire un députés et sénateurs se
sont mis d'accord sur un même texte qui
reprend pour l'essentiel la version du
sénat le projet de loi comporte
notamment le pass and i ter aux
frontières mais aussi la réintégration
des soignants non vaccinés si la haute
autorité hôtelier autorise ça vient de
chiens
députés et sénateurs ont trouvé un
accord sur le projet de loi sanitaire un
accord totalement alignée sur la version
du sénat en position de force dans ces
négociations
supprimé par les députés le certificat
sanitaire a été rétablie pour les
voyages extrait hexagonaux en provenance
de l'étranger et des outre mer avec des
conditions plus restrictives proposée
par le sénat uniquement en cas
d'apparition d'un nouveau variant
particulièrement menaçants et seulement
si le système de santé local est saturé
concernant l'outre-mer dans tous les cas
le retour du pass vaccinale est exclu
seul un test qu'ovide pourrait être
exigé vous pouvez être vaccinés
contagieux si vous voulez protéger les
français contre l'importation d'un
variant très grave il faut donc faire
quelque chose de plus fort encore est
cette chose cette chose la plus efficace
c'est le test avant par exemple de
prendre l'avion il faut que le test soit
négatif et c'est pour ces raisons
scientifiques que nous avons voulu
imposer le test uniquement d'ailleurs si
invariants très grave apparaît quelque
part la version finale du texte reprend
une proposition du sénat sur la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
ce ne serait plus au gouvernement mais
est la haute autorité de santé de
décider quand ils seront autorisés à
retrouver leur poste la majorité
présidentielle y était opposée et a dû
céder à contrecoeur pour obtenir un
accord et sauver son projet de loi
sanitaire je redis que cet article est
inefficace inutile et dangereux et que
par ailleurs au regard de ce qu'ont été
les avis du conseil scientifique de
l'académie de médecine je ne doute pas
un instant que l'avis de la haute
autorité de santé qui lie l'avis du
gouvernement qui lie la décision du
gouvernement sur la question de la
réintégration des soignants soit de même
nature dernier ajout du sénat la fin de
l'état d'urgence est actée noir sur
blanc au 31 juillet l'exécutif ne pourra
plus décrété de confinement ou de
couvre-feu sans repasser par le
parlement le président hervé marseille
l'un des points les plus polémiques de
ce texte c'est surtout la réintégration
des soignantes non vaccinés est ce que
vous y êtes personnellement favorable
sur le principe non nous n'y sommes pas
favorables mais on en trouver un
compromis qui consiste à saisir la haute
autorité de santé pour demander son avis
dès que les circonstances le permettront
la réintégration parce qu'il est vrai
que
n'a besoin des soignants aussi dans les
autres mais il a fallu donc ces dames
forme de chantage dans ce marché parce
que c'était le mot employé par olivier
ferrand et disait le parlementarisme
c'est pas du chantage en parlant de la
réintégration dit alors être compromis
justement à un moment où vous avez des
idées il faut aller vers l'autre et puis
dire écoutez voilà on se met d'accord en
revanche l'abandon à la référence du
vaccin pour passer les matières ça c'est
une concession faite pour que
l'assemblée puisse voter c'est forcément
un test pcr c'est ça oui d'accord mais
quand on explique toutes sortes de
choses j'entends mais la vérité vraie
c'est quand même que c'est là aussi un
compromis une concession faite pour que
ça soit votée à l'assemblée nationale
alors est ce que vous pensez en tout cas
que cette concession va vraiment changer
quelque chose au sein des services
d'urgence impossible de savoir au fond
combien de soignants sont concernés un
sénateur a posé la question à au
ministre qui était auditionné
entre ceux qui sont en congés suspendu
qu'est-ce que je pense qu'il faut que la
commission des affaires sociales se
penche sur le sujet qu'on sache
exactement qui est concerné et puis que
ben ma foi les autorités de santé la
haute autorité donne un avis parce que
c'est vrai que s'il y a plus d'état
d'urgence et qu'il ya plus de pandémie
sa salle s'interroger liste de la santé
ne puisse pas répondre à ce genre de
question on a vu ce type de données sont
un peu surprenant ne pas savoir combien
de gens on a mis dehors parce que la
vérité vraie c'est quand même qu'on a
mis des gens dehors on la paye plus
entre ceux qui sont suspendus ceux qui
sont en congés sont définitivement pas
claires at dawn hameau badji frac de
savoir il va falloir d'urgence qu'on
nous le sommes parce que c'est quand
même important est ce que ce message
s'est tu ce post est possible
réintégration des soignants dont thaksin
et c'est aussi un message politique un
message politique pour les antilles vaac
sous pour ceux qui sont déçus de la
façon dont cette pandémie a été géré je
crois que c'est aussi un message
d'apaisement à un moment donné la
pandémie espérons qu'elle ne prospère
plus est derrière nous elle a des effets
et en particulier sur le plan social je
crois qu'il ya eu beaucoup de débats des
débats virulents il ya des gens qui
effectivement été fondamentalement
ti'vac ce jusqu'à perdre leur emploi et
c'est quelque chose de fort et donc il
faut aussi rechercher l'apaisement et
savoir tourner la page alors vous avez
réussi députés et sénateurs à vous
entendre sur la rédaction d'un texte
commun issu de la commission mixte
militaire sénateurs et députés à parité
néanmoins il reste un vote à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat qui aura lieu ce
lundi à l'assemblée est-ce que vous
pensez que ce texte peut encore être
rejetée alors c'est rarissime je crois
qu'il s'est déjà produit un cas comme ça
oui malgré le compromis ce qui peut y
avoir encore un coup de tous horizons on
peut tout imaginer partir du moment où
il ya un vote on peut imaginer qu'ils
soient négatifs il faut pas le souhaiter
et ce serait une mauvaise image
on donnerait du parlement etc
les acteurs et c'est là dessus je pense
à l'esprit de responsabilité qui doit
animer tout le monde il faut voter ce
texte ce texte il avait surtout fait
parler de lui initialement un parent le
rejet de l'article 2 celui qui donc un
store finalement un éventuel test pcr
aux frontières en cas de variants
dangereux ou avec l'outre-mer si les
services sont saturés est-ce que là
dedans le sénat à servier bien à sauver
le gouvernement a est venu à la
rescousse du gouvernement peut le dire
comme ça mais je voulais dit tout à
l'heure et on peut aussi imaginer que
c'est un compromis et qu'il faut savoir
faire des gestes nous nous avions un
amendement qu'à porter mon ami
bonnecarrère nous avons été battus pour
nous volions rétablir le pass vaccinale
ce qui a toujours été la ligne ici au
sénat remet bon il ya une situation
nouvelle donc il ya une réflexion nous
mais vous permettez quand même quelque
part au gouvernement d'avoir la majorité
qu'il n'a pas si je puis dire quels
bénéfices en tirez vous c'est pas de
bénéfices simplement le bénéfice d'être
responsable et de se dire que on a fait
une oeuvre utile et que ce texte
normalement devra être voté allez on va
terminer avec marseille avec et bien les
incendies au coeur des questions au
gouvernement au sénat a pas moins de six
questions sur le sujet mercredi dernier
alors que les forêts continuent de
brûler en gironde ou encore en bretagne
les sénateurs ont déploré le manque de
canadairs et l'état de la flotte
française écouter ait cet échange
mercredi notre département ne dispose
d'aucun canadair à demeure en provenance
de nîmes et ils sont arrivés plus de 12
heures après le début de l'incendié
autrefois il était à mérignac nous le
savons tous chaque minute de gagner est
primordial propriété de l'état leur
maintenance a été déléguée à un
prestataire privé seulement quatre
avions dash sur 6 9 canadairs sur douze
sont en mesure de voler les deux tiers
ont plus de 25 ans nous luttons contre
la crise climatique avec des moyens du
siècle passé monsieur le ministre
comptez vous renforcer la flotte
européenne et nationale relocalisé au
moins deux canadairs dans le sud-ouest
21 avions sont actuellement mobilisées
12 canadair
6dans 3 beach qui sont aujourd'hui
mobilisés sur ces feux ce déploiement
sans précédent n'a été possible que
parce que nous avons augmenté ces cinq
dernières années le budget de la
sécurité civile de plus de 44%
l'ensemble des moyens prévus dans le
cadre de l'ordre national d'opération
des feux de forêt est engagé et monsieur
le sénateur l'heure n'est pas
aujourd'hui à la polémique mais à la
solidarité
et mercredi emmanuel macron a déclaré
qu'il fallait plus deux canadair en
acheter plus haut niveau européen à ce
que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce qu'il faut revoir notre flotte et
localiser les canadair un peu partout
sur le territoire face à la nouvelle
donne des incendies oui il ya une
mission actuellement en cours
mon ami pascal martin heynckes loisier
méga feux
et donc qu'il va y avoir des
préconisations qu'on connaît déjà bien
sûr faut des moyens c'est toujours ce
qu'on demande quand il y en a quelque
chose la plus grande flotte durable deux
canadair ça suffit pas la preuve c'est
que il faut réfléchir à leur déploiement
on voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup d'avions
qui sont en maintenance donc à
l'évidence faut des moyens
supplémentaires mais pas qu'eux aussi
une politique de prévention il faut
aussi une politique liée à
l'urbanisation parce qu'on a maintenant
des constructions très près des forêts
ça pose un problème
politique de prévention et d'éducation
pour qu'on dise aux gens comment il faut
faire il ya le problème du
débroussaillement il ya tous âges et à
sa vue sur plusieurs peuples quelle est
la priorité de tous à ce que c'est un
problème de moyens pour même de belles
caisses la priorité c'est des moyens
parce que
je veux dire canadair à polémique pour
reprendre la zone hier de la caisse
s'est passé mercredi il s'agit pas de
polémiquer il s'agit simplement de tirer
les conséquences de problèmes qui sont
dramatiques pour beaucoup de familles et
est là encore il faut saluer bien sûr
les pompiers les policiers mais aussi
tous les élus locaux parce que voir
toutes ces petites communes où c'est le
maire et conseillers municipaux qui ont
été sur le terrain et c'est important et
on a parlé de l'europe je crois aussi
qu'il faut une réflexion avec l'europe
parce que ça concerne bien sûr la grèce
ça concerne tous les pays du sud et donc
là encore il faut avoir une politique
fait rien mais aussi des hommes des
soldats du feu qui lutte pied à pied
d'oeuvre est-ce que avec dans des
conditions assez difficiles est-ce qu'il
faut revaloriser éventuellement aussi le
métier de sapeur pompier a beaucoup de
valeur dont terre dans les propositions
je crois savoir qu'il ya une réflexion
aussi sur le statut des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires notamment leur recrutement
leur énumération
leur statut ils sont rémunérés entre 7
et 9 euros du bien suffisant dit le
sénateur bio sur natal bien sûr et donc
je crois que tous ces choses là tous ces
travaux là il va falloir rapidement les
mettre en oeuvre parce qu'on voit bien
que c'est chaque année que il ya des
drames vécus dans nos régions est-ce que
c'est pas aussi une illustration en acte
du réchauffement climatique puisqu'on
l'a vu on a aujourd'hui bien des feux
avec la canicule qui ont sont allés
jusque dans le nord il ya eu aussi des
incendies du côté de londres qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire ce contexte là bien
sûr il ya le réchauffement climatique et
toute la politique qui doit être mené
par les états mais il ya aussi les actes
parce qu'il ya aussi des actes de
délinquance des gens qui encore mettre
le feu oui donc le catalan dir est assez
dramatique c'est dramatique donc la
police fait la gendarmerie font le
nécessaire la justice ces vies mais je
crois qu'il ya une politique de
prévention de surveillance d'actions sur
le terrain sur l'action climatique mais
ça ça va prendre du temps mais c'est une
course contre la montre sans fin
il ya beaucoup de problèmes sur le plan
climatique qui sont actuels il va
falloir prendre des mesures immédiates
parce qu'on sait très bien que ça va
prendre du temps pour qu'il y ait des
effets et pour que la bouffe que ça
bouclé à ce que dans ce contexte vous
comprenez les oppositions du coût des
écologistes à un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises dans le
projet doit pouvoir d'achat voilà pour
notamment pouvoir relancer
éventuellement le charbon et c'est face
à la crise énergétique
oui enfin ils sont sympathiques les
écologistes 1 on les a écoutés ils nous
ont fait faire beaucoup de bêtises quand
même hein on affirmé comment si vous
visez bon je baille ils nous ont fait
fermer fessenheim on a des usines qui
n'ont pas été maintenant cette politique
depuis une dizaine d'années nous a
conduit aujourd'hui à en catastrophe
revenir en arrière pour préparer l'hiver
parce qu'on nous dit maintenant on va
avoir des coupures à cause de ce qui se
passe en ukraine avec les russes et donc
c'est quand même insupportable et ya
jamais eu de débat sur tous à
l'énergie merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
cette émission merci la semaine
prochaine avec un autre invité
[Musique]